certains qualifieront cette séquence de
gênante d'autres de dérapage hier soir
le candidat est reine aux législatives
gérard vos laurie a brandi une photo de
sa femme en plein débat sur france 3
rhône alpes photo de ma femme merci
alors que la candidate du parti
renaissance sarah peillon attaqué le
rassemblement national sur ses idées
extrémistes et quand vous dites que vous
n'êtes pas exprès monsieur natu pa pour
la préférence nationale marie-charlotte
garin candidate de la nouvelle union des
gauches a renchéri en fustigeant le
parti le jeu de la dédiabolisation du
rassemblement national du personnes donc
on peut dire autant qu'on veut qu'on
n'est pas extrême à partir du moment
appartient à un parti extrémiste ça
restera un ingrédient le candidat de la
3e circonscription du rhône gérard vos
laurie s'est alors défendu en montrant
une photo de sa femme d'origine
rwandaise et à la couleur de peau noire
index prémédité qui a surpris voire
indignés les invités sur le plateau soit
que ce que la vie privée dans l'année
dans glh privé on est dans un débat
politique alors un candidat et rennes
fait polémique en brandissant la photo
de sa femme noire pour prouver qu'il
n'est pas raciste comprenez vous le
lynchage ce soir genlissiens réagi dans
tpm p
alors merci jean merci à m être avec
nous soit vous avez des chiffres encore
est ce que vous comprenez le lynchage
médiatique vous avez aux petites
pancartes jura dit ne le comprends pas
non moi je n'aime pas les lynchages
médiatiques j'aime pas la violence
j'aime pas qu'on insulte j'aime pas
qu'on menace lorsqu'il ya une faculté
aujourd'hui a menacé insulté à voile
assez c'est beaucoup trop violent et ses
procès en racisme pour tout et n'importe
quoi je trouve que c'est choquant après
je trouve que son geste à lui est
totalement ridicule stade et lui montre
la photo de sa femme comme c'est un
objet un trophée lors de caution voyez
voilà j'ai une femme noire je pars à 6
c'est dégueulasse mais en même temps
est-ce qu'on a droit d'être au
rassemblement national et ne pas avoir
de procès en racisme pour tout tout le
temps ici avant l'élection
présidentielle il ya beaucoup de
chroniqueurs qui ont dit oui il m'a
arrêté dire que les électeurs duration
nationale sont racistes donc voilà donc
je vois pas pourquoi ce monsieur serait
plus racistes que ses électeurs voilà
donc en fait tout est ridicule dans ce
débat alors non le beau film il ce linge
tout seul en fait y'a pas besoin de nous
le lyncher c'est à dire que son geste
est ridicule sortir une photo d'une
femme noire comme si on ne pouvait pas
être marié avec une femme noire et avoir
des pensées racistes comme si un homme
misogyne ne pouvait pas être marié avec
une femme tout ça c'est de l'ordre de
l'absurde mais je pense que le lyncher
par contre on a tort parce que beaucoup
de gens font ce mode de fonctionnement
qui est con mais qui méritent pas qu'on
le jette en pâture belle béatrice boxe
dans son geste et est absolument
ridicule en plus apparemment c'était
prémédité puisqu'il avait déjà à la
photo sur le dossier donc il savait
qu'il allait faire ça maintenant je suis
contrôlé lynchage je me bats ici pour
compterait pas les gens de fachos toute
la journée de racisme de complotiste de
voilà de caricatures donc je suis contre
le lynchage genlissiens vous comprenez
vous bah écoutez elles surviennent
lynchage ou est ce qu'on peut comprendre
qu'un qu'un homme qui est marié avec une
femme de couleur qui partage sa vie
qu'il aime est ce qu'on peut comprendre
qu'à un moment ils puissent se sentir
agacé blessée par le fait qu on lui sort
tout le temps qu'il est raciste qu'il
est d'extrême droite qui les fascistes
est-ce que c'est pas simplement sa
réaction n'est pas simplement le crible
que du coeur d'un homme qui se sent
effectivement agressés et blessés dans
ses sentiments profonds ça c'est sûr là
sur la forme maintenant sur le fond
c'est vrai qu'on en a marre on en a ras
l'oignon d'être en permanence en
permanence traité de raciste fasciste à
chaque fois qu'on va faire un essai de
bowe et sont nombreux hm fois
connaissait les oignons et à chaque fois
qu'on essaye de à chaque fois qu'on
essaye de de défendre l'identité
française ou de défendre les agressions
identité a mis la france à chaque fois
on est traités de la même manière alors
moi je veux soutenir ce monsieur
moi-même j'appartiens à une mouvance
politique depuis des années déjà qu'on
traite d'antisémite et bien voilà ce que
j'ai chez moi j'y arrive au
sénat nous que j'ai chez moi alors est
ce que est ce que ça va me suffire on va
continuer pendant des lustres encore à
avoir des procès d'antisémitisme
enracine simplement parce qu'on a le
malheur de défendre la france je crois
qu'il faut arrêter ces bêtises on a
aujourd'hui entre 40 et 45% des français
qui votent pour un mouvement que ce soit
le rassemblement national que ce soit
eric zemmour que ce soit ni nicolas
dupont aignan qui votent pour un nouveau
code pour des mouvements qu'on va dire
patriotiques ou des mouvements nationaux
est ce qu'on peut admettre l'idée que
non il n'ya pas 45% des français
ils sont racistes qui sont antisémites a
un moment faut arrêter les bêtises
d'accord mais bon alors oui d'accord
mais le fait de mettre une ranocchia ou
de doudou de mettre la photo passe et ça
c'est le niveau zéro de l'argument jeudi
l attendais mais j'ai quand même jean
c'est comme quand j'entends à moi je
suis pas raciste j'aime le fait ce coup
ce niveau
c'est le cas on peut on peut en voir
d'autres l'arrivée rien excuser moi
c'est exactement le même argument qui
est de dire tu vote front national tu
vois tu eric zemmour donc tu es un
raciste c'est pareil c'est là l'argument
de nommer lui-même au ras des
pâquerettes l'autre c'est vous c'est
vous qui mettez le démasque on peut
alors justement ne tirons pas le débat à
ce niveau là et c'est le moment je suis
désolé à un moment à un moment il faut
des symboles forts d'ailleurs je précise
quelque chose quand on tente on est
quand il s'agit de brandir des gens de
la diversité quand quand le système
gauche au progressisme nous brandit des
hommes de couleur ou des femmes racisées
comme ils disent pour nous montrer que
la diversité à ses droits que sa
diversité a ses entrées personne n'en
parle quand harry roselmack le
présentateur ça qu'on apprend qu'on
avait présentée à l'époque qu'on avait
présentée à l'époque comme un
présentateur noir dans la diversité
beaucoup les hommes de couleur arrive à
la télé à ce moment personne n'a dit à
ce moment-là mais attendez mais c'est
quoi cet argument est on là il est là
parce qu'il est il est talentueux il est
alors que c'est un bon journaliste et
elle pourquoi pourquoi insister sur la
couleur de peau à ce qu'ils ont compté
dans ces
conditions peut il
s'agit de broglie représentait ans il
s'agit de brandir des rokhaya diallo ou
inhalés ou des goûts des global mans des
gens qui sont de la diversité qui
n'aiment pas la france ou en tout cas
quand le système qui n'aiment pas la
france brandit ses exemples là on
applaudit on dit waouw c'est magnifique
mais quand le système national brandit
des gens qui sont assimilés qui aiment
la france parce que je vous dit quelque
chose ce monsieur qui brandit les peuls
la photo de son épouse il avait pas
besoin de le faire parce qu'en réalité
au rassemblement national chez eric
zemmour ou zeppelin de maghrébins
d'africains dodo d'origine qui milite à
marier 9 de français d'origine immigrée
france qui milite et milite pour des
mouvements nationaux parce qu'ils sont
assimilés et parce qu'ils croient en la
france telle qu'on l'a de vous nous la
défendons donc arretez de tours à 6 et 2
ces mamans mais non mais non traité de
raciste c'est vous qui et racisées
avant de prendre une branlée aux
élections - vous étiez intelligent
vous n'êtes pas besoin de prendre une
branlée aux élections pour ne pas l'être
mais phoneo dix mots là
[Applaudissements]
vous en êtes à sortait des objets des
photos dédicacées monolithe noir pour
pour donner les brevet d'antiracisme
grotesque mais pas alors que la femme
est un objet va nous exhiber comme les
colons esclavagistes à l'époque exhibe
une maîtresse noir c'est exactement là
où vous allez arrêter ces jeux vous est
honteux c'est gilles verdez gilles femme
vous sortez totalement de la vie privée
j'ai gardé vous et vos collègues exhibé
une photo de froid c'est absolument se
rendra pas si nous en est là c'est que
vous n'avez plus rien du tout c'est fait
c'est parce que des cra poussins et des
mires midou lui et vous
voilà et c'est ça qui vient vous vous
empêchez pas vous même de prendre un
exemple quand on vous traite de raciste
alors arrêté et géraldine toi tu ne veux
pas mais tu étais d'accord avec jean
survie non c'est à dire qu'en fait je
comprends ce que dit jean même si je ne
partage absolument pas ses idées
effectivement j'ai comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure je trouve qu'effectivement ce
monsieur la caution brandi cette femme
comme un trophée une sorte de femme
objet comme ça je trouve que comme l'a
dit valérie c'est le degré zéro de
l'argumentation et en même temps gilles
on peut te retourner le le concept en
fait on peut être heureux retournez-les
argumentation c'est à dire que nous on
vient ici sûreté pmp avec nos vies avec
nos vies intimes avec nos vies privées
avec nos parcours et tu ne peux pas dire
que toi ici tu n'as pas parler aussi de
fatou 2 par rapport au sénégal de
l'islam et toi tu l'as dit comme un
trophée
manuel est quand même avec comme un
trophée il a proposé de venir vous
répondre la semaine prochaine chez
passionné les
français
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce niveau des fonctions pour lui
demander pour lui demander sa main c'est
quand même malgré tout bon jour c'est
jouer
raymond domenech fait mal mais on part
tout ce dont on ne parle tous on part
tous quand même de nos vies de nos
parcours et l'agencé plateau y est bien
donc je ne parle pas de fatou sur le
plateau aussi alors mauvais alors il a
droit de le faire donc il est donc de la
même manière il parle de sa femme mais
patatras
c'est difficile n'est pas raciste moi
bien sûr été servis par ces grands
risques de position c'est par rapport à
ça pas du tout il parle de sa vie privée
il a droit de parler de sa femme simone
qui concerne est parfaite c'est quand je
suis consterné par les arguments de jean
messia cet homme et par les miens alors
et par celles et ceux de gérard vienne
aussi cet homme qui brandit cette photo
comme un espèce de totem d'immunité qui
l'autoriserait à voir dès le
biberon il brandit cette image comme un
trophée qu'il autoriserait avoir des
pensées nauséabondes qui peuvent être
perçus comme raciste et olfactif
maintenant pourquoi est-ce que vous ne
trouvez pas de vrais arguments solides
pour prouver que vous n'êtes pas raciste
peut-être parce que vous n'en avez pas
mais attends je alors % des français
thales a cédé ma vie mais je vais
quand le service public france
télévisions
officieusement
fait des progressions de carrière à des
gens parce qu'ils sont racisées pour les
montres et les exhiber à la télé pour
montrer que france télévisions est
ouverte à tout le monde pourquoi et pour
montrer qui est surtout qu'ils ne sont
pas racistes pourquoi personne n'en
parle de ça pourquoi ça passe crème 1
c'est une bonne chose
ce cas pourquoi dans un cas quand on
instrumentalise des gens de couleurs ou
des gens d'origine immigrée pour moudre
pour montrer qu'on n'est pas raciste
quand on est de gauche progressiste ça
passe genre et quand on est patriote au
national quand on instrumentalise de la
même manière et qu'on montre par des
exemples probants par des exemples
emblématiques que nous ne sommes pas
racistes la maison
mais il faut crise télévision n'est pas
taxé de raciste
présente est imminent et la wii face au
passage que ses idées sont perçus comme
raciste là maintenant et attend quand
ils ne sont pas représentatifs ils sont
précisément taxé de racisme du tout et
donc pour montré des gages aux anti
racistes ils vont effectivement
accélérer les carrières de ce qu'ils
appellent les racisées pour que pour les
mettre en devanture et les affiches et
les travaux l'a pas bien qu'il y ait
plein de gens de toutes les couleurs et
de toutes les religions à soit les
chaînes moi personnellement je m'en fous
moi ce qui compte c'est que les gens qui
sont sur les chaînes et sur les chefs
soient des gens compétents c'est là
qu'elle que soit vous attendez lâché je
suis pas un obsédé de la couleur de peau
1 contrairement au hajj à ceux qui
parlent de racine et le mot racisées
d'ailleurs elle était amendé par qui
c'est pas par l'extrême droite le mot
raciste est un mot trop cher et ça on se
dit on verra ça en dit long le mont
racisées les ateliers racisées interdit
aux blancs c'est pas les essais pas
l'extrême droite qui les organisent
c'est les gens de gauche dont qui est
obsédé par la race dont ce pays les gens
de gauche et les autres guillemets
progressiste qui sont réellement
remplacement pardon c'est pas humain
le placement c'est pas une théorie c'est
une réalité donc ça excusez moi vous
pourriez avoir raison mais là c'est fort
lui
todd est au tarif un micro aussi willens
s'il avait argumenté après avoir montré
la photo il montre juste la photo qu'il
avait prévu de les gêner avant la
séquence on a l'impression qu'ils
attendent la dégainer y la montre il
repose par un seul argument si après
pendant dix minutes il avait argumenté
en expliquant un certain nombre de
chômeurs était moins ridicule là en
l'occurrence il est ridicule parce qu'il
montre la photo et me posent la photo
est belle claquette oui oui mais c'est
vrai aussi que la personne qui est en
face de lui le traité de raciste sans
forcément le connaître je vais qui
débloque il était où il donne des
arguments c'est pas un argument montrez
nous tous maintenant tu vas prouver tpc
c est ainsi qu ici on ici on développe
des idées chocs complète son ministre le
monde tu prouves que t'es pas bien passé
on développe des idées on brandit pas
une photo qu'on repose en se taisant
après c'est comme ça complètement
différent si la pêche tout ça est ce ce
maladroit mais c'est vrai mais ce qui
l'est moins à force d'être 118 218
médaille mais
c'est quoi 218 mais je vous ai dit ouais
je trouvais que c'était le degré zéro de
la politique et que c'est pas un
argument c'est à dire que
j'entends ce que dit jean en disant que
des gens dont le loup le renard et la
belette activement peut-être que ce
monsieur s'est trouvé blessé earth et
que donc il a dégainé en même temps il
ya une sorte de préparation parce que
t'as pas une photo a4 de ta femme parce
que c'est très aimable valérie tout le
monde aime tout le monde sait très bien
que quand on arrive avec une étiquette
et rennes ou une étiquette d'eric
zemmour ou de je-ne-sais-quoi laiteries
dans l'hexagone tu vas tu as les façons
tu vas y avoir droit tu vas avoir
droit racistes et/ou toi maintenant moi
je vais très bien non mais t'es où toi
tu fais quoi là bas il noté il était là
en fait je vois là j'ai repris
l'institut apollon d'accord
apollon 13 noms paul on le dieu grec et
la politique là tu regrettes tu seras
qui s'est rien passé le dû à quoi s'est
donné trois points un jeu sans ballon il
est dur de couasse et de la beauté
regarde moi c'est pareil
[Rires]
non mais c'est finir que tu es plus avec
eux reconquête battu et tué le tu es au
courant quand même moi je vais te dire
je débarquais tu as fini par une dépêche
afp une émission chez moi on dénie
terminé en hausse alors que tu découvres
que tu es une rockstar en fait je sais
pas faire
[Rires]
prier c'est quoi les studios apollon
basse et inserts de réflexion qui est
employé j'aimerais c'est ça ouais
ça m'arrive êtes combien ses tanks non
mais c'est parce que c'est réfléchir lui
donc c'est pour ça qu'il convient dans
le cercle balaj le ça fait quatre mois
qu'il est en jachère
rallumera il faudra du match et non les
quelques-uns avant on est quelques-uns
c'est ça vous aurez plus que je vous
dise que je suis tout seul vous êtes
combien mais
vraiment il ya guillaume messia
jean baptiste messieurs
directement
les genres et la politique vous allez me
lever le pied non le fond vous manqué
trop ce pour quoi vous allez me refaire
de la télé manquer est-ce que vous
manquiez la télé est ce que vous me dire
si je suis invité c'est qu'apparemment
c'est lui qui d'ordinaire des gens
derrière lui et lui eric zemmour ils ont
emmené des gens derrière eux ils ont
parlé aux français tous les soirs en
leur disant pendant la campagne on va
vous sortir de là on va vous m'ont donné
une vie meilleure vous allez voir la
france sera plus belle avec nous vous
allez voir l'oeil sait même plus où il
est là il sait pas si la tp un pays
c'est pas si la pathétique non mais je
trouve ça très grave c'est très grave
c'est très beau ça très très loin
d'avoir menti aux gens et en cavale
finalement vous devriez rester dans la
politique coûte que coûte pour sauver le
voyagiste dans un truc je demande
la vérité car
selon moi j'ai pas de problème joyeux
comme s'y est engagé dans la politique
et je n'ai pas réussi et ne je dis juste
que quand on promet aux français normand
on les lâche pas là vous partez pour
nous aimer ce que vous allez
progressiste est bienveillante 5 judo de
sancerre juge herman comment tu vas
choyé bienveillant de moi si je suis
malade en soi et ne jamais changer au
bout de six mois je suis méchant parce
que je suis déçu service
d ailleurs même en fait tu veux saison
de paris jamais
mais c'est sérieux la folie perdu les
élections raymond commencent
à apparaître sur ces 8 c'est sérieux la
mine atticus et une diction et tu le
fais comme intra la loi martiale et eddy
savoie
mais je suis dit est ce que je peux et
ce que je me tue son invention c'est une
attaque mais cela
ne va pas vous vous attaquez
pas la risée sur marlène marleix veut
demeurer
j'entendais les fringues superbe recrue
autour de la terre et la lune et je me
suis dit mais non
est ce que dans la société civile a fait
des choses pour un ordinaire pour
l'égalité alors justement les
discriminations on est pro on lui
proposait elle pense qu'elle peut aider
grâce à son expérience m'a d'abord fait
une carrière politique bien que de trois
ans c'est fini comme si elles
étaient cachées apprécier les produits
ce qu'ils font à des niveaux de
continuer reymond travaillent à la
conviction je préfère ça les gens tu vas
répondre à sa patrie
la politique c'est effectivement ça peut
être un engagement un jeu non ça peut
être un engagement j'en ai déjà usé
votre engagement et vous le savez mais
ça peut aussi être des idées à défendre
dans toute attaque serre que ce soit
dans les médias radio par écrit voilà là
peu de la politique c'est pas simplement
un vecteur louis l'engagement partisan
dans un parti politique effectivement
c'est faire de la politique mais c'est
pas le seul comment dire que ce n'est
pas le seul engagement qu'on peut avoir
on peut défendre ses idées ailleurs que
dans un parti politique
français c'est vous allez sortir de la
merde présenter sa nature
c'est paris qui se présente ou personne
va voter pour lui
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas ils ont plus de chance de
voter pour moi de voter pour un inconnu
le soleil